hey guys Wes here and we're gonna build
a simple image gallery where we can
actually upload images to Azure blob
storage okay so here is a very brief
look at the application that we'll be
building over this series so we have a
very simple image gallery application
it's built completely in asp.net core
2.0 using asp.net core MVC and so you'll
see that we have a gallery page here
with just a few images in it at the
moment and we can click on any one of
these images and go to a simple detailed
view so for now that's what we have we
have some metadata on each of these
images including a title when the image
was created as well as the tags that
will actually build out a search feature
to allow users to search for images so
our application will grow beyond this
point we'll also have the ability to
upload new images and have those images
stored in the cloud using Azure blob
storage so that we'll be building out a
complete MVC application with a service
layer and a web layer and we'll use a
sequel server as our back-end so you
want to make sure that you have asp.net
core 2.0 installed on your machine and
sequel server management studio with
sequel server Express installed I'll be
using visual studio 2017 to do all the
coding for this series as well so if
you'd like to follow along directly
I would recommend just downloading the
free version of Visual Studio 2017 as
well start out by using some images that
are hosted remotely just to kind of show
how the web layer works and then we'll
move on to hosting images locally on our
own machine and then finally hosting
images as I mentioned in the cloud on
Azure so we'll work our way there over
the course the next several videos and
yeah I hope you enjoy the series okay so
let's go ahead and fire up Visual Studio
and we're going to create a new project
and we will select asp.net core web
application
and I'm just gonna call this simple
image gallery and just be sure to pick a
location maybe with other development
projects that you're working on and then
we will create a directory for the
solution and also create a git
repository here so we'll select ok and
then we'll have the option to choose
from a number of different templates now
that we're using asp.net core 2.0 so
first of all make sure that we are using
dotnet core and that we're using
specifically asp.net core 2.0 and then
we're just gonna select the web
application which will be implementing
the model-view-controller pattern and
we're not going to worry about
authentication for this particular
version of the app so this will just
take a moment and it is going to
scaffold out a very simple MVC app for
us which we'll see here in just a moment
so we have a few different folders we
have directories for our controllers
models and views and if we just take a
peek in here we can see that we have a
simple home controller and this has got
a few actions on it we have an index
about and contact action and some
corresponding views here it looks like
and then one simple view model here
looks like for an error view so that's
all good we won't be really using any of
the scaffolded out MVC stuff we'll just
be writing our own here but we will use
these directories and you can see we
have an app settings that JSON file
powered I chase on file and a bundle
config and then we have our program that
CS and startup dot CS so you'll be
familiar with these files if you're
coming from
asp.net core 1.0 and there are some
differences here if we take a look in
programmed at CS you can see that we
have
and i webhost build webhost method here
and we're just calling create default
builder on it so there's a lot that's
actually kind of packaged into this
method which is something that's quite a
bit different from asp.net core 1.0 so
we won't go into all the details here in
this particular series but just be aware
that this is still the main entry point
for our web app then if we take a look
in our startup that CS class and we
scroll down a bit you can see that we
have the constructor here and we have
this configure services method still
this will be where we register services
for dependency injection into our
controllers and we'll have just probably
one or two simple services for this
series and then we have this configure
method and this is where we configure
our HTTP request pipeline so our
middleware here you can see that we're
the same things like use static files
we'll take a look at those in a moment
here use MVC and then we show how we
actually are going to configure our
routes and our routing for this
application so in this case we will have
like our app slash controller slash
action and then some optional ID you can
also see that we have the ability to
change change some things rather easily
here depending on whether we're in a
development environment or a production
or a staging or environment however we'd
like to configure that we have the
ability here to do things like for
example use developer exception page
where we might do things like actually
show the stacked rates for a particular
error that gets thrown in the browser
otherwise we have some custom error page
so we can do sorts of different types of
configuration like that here and that's
all handled in our configure method
that's in the startup class okay so
we'll be revisiting this soon for now
let's go ahead and create our first
controller so if we expand controllers
here we won't worry about our home
controller for now I'm going to do is go
ahead and add a new controller and we'll
minimal dependencies so go ahead and
right-click on controllers and we'll add
a new controller and we'll just make it
an empty MVC controller and we're gonna
call it image gallery controller or
let's just call it actually a gallery
controller and so this is gonna scaffold
out a very basic controller class for us
so you can see that it's extending this
controller base class this is coming
from asp net core MVC and then we have a
simple index action that's just
returning an empty UVU so let's just
kind of get right into it here we we're
gonna have a gallery and so we have to
think about what we actually want to
pass in terms of a model to the view
that represents our gallery so we know
for sure that we're going to store that
in a view model so we'll save our model
is equal to and we'll make a new gallery
index model which of course we'll have
to create
and then we'll pass this to our view so
let's go ahead and create this class
we're gonna create that in our models
folder so this models folder will
contain all of our view models we'll go
ahead and add a new class call it
gallery index model and so now let's
just think about the type of data that
we'd like the user to see or interact
with on our gallery index page so first
of all we'll have a series of images of
course for the user to perhaps click on
so we'll have an enumerable collection
of gallery images and this will be
another type that we need to create
we'll call this property images and then
we'll write our auto property here okay
and then the next thing that I'd like to
provide on our gallery index view is a
search box that a user could perhaps
write a query and get images that have
you know some metadata associated with
whatever the users queried returned back
to this view so we can do is go ahead
and create a string search query
and we'll use this particular property
to store that users input okay so now
clearly we need to create a gallery
image model but in this case I'd like
this to actually be a domain model or an
entity model rather than a view model so
this will map directly to a record in
our database
perhaps in like a gallery images table
so for that I'm actually going to create
a new project in our solution so we'll
go ahead and right click here and we'll
add a new project in this case it's just
going to be a dead net core class
library and we're going to call it
simple image gallery dot data and you
can see that it's gonna create a simple
class here just called class one and
we'll use this class as our dbcontext so
let's call it simple image gallery
dbcontext and will extend dbcontext so
we'll actually need to add a few
packages here now to set this up so if
we right click on simple image gallery
data so our data project and we're going
to select manage NuGet packages and then
we'll select browse and first of all we
need to bring in Microsoft dot any
framework or so we'll go ahead and
install that and we'll accept the terms
next we're going to install entity
framework or dot
tools this should allow us to actually
run database migrations from our package
manager console which we'll look at in
just a little while and then we'll also
install any framework or that sequel
server we use sequel server as our
back-end for this project okay with
those dependencies install I'm just
going to go ahead and close this tab and
now we should import Microsoft in any
framework or dot DB context here the
other thing I'm gonna do is actually
rename this file from class 1 to simple
image gallery DB context
okay so we can kind of think of our
dbcontext as our database and the
particular database that will be the
backend for this application and so what
we need to do here is actually create a
constructor so we'll just say public
central image gallery dbcontext and will
instantiate that with some dbcontext
options and then we'll call base options
to ensure that this gets passed to ETB
contacts base class so here's our simple
constructor and then in our DB context
class so in this class we're actually
going to define some DB sets and these
will represent in a sense the tables
that will be in our simple image gallery
database and so we're gonna have a
public DB set of gallery images and
we'll call this table gallery images and
then write our auto profit here and so
this gallery image is the same entity
model that we would then also like to
use at some point in one of our views
and our gallery index view here so if we
come back what I'm going to do is now
actually create a new folder in our data
project called models and then here
we'll add our class for our gallery
image okay so make this class public
and now we have to think a little bit
about what particular properties we
would like to have on an instance of a
gallery image so first of all let's just
go ahead and give each of our images a
simple title and then perhaps we'll have
a date time or when that image was
created and since we'll be storing the
images in the cloud what I'm going to do
is create a URL string that we can use
to actually point to you know the
location of that image on the web that
we can then you know use that to create
things like image tags and links when we
actually start building out our views so
each gallery image will have a specific
URL or it's hosted and then maybe
finally we'll have this collection of
strings and this will represent the tags
that are on that particular image so
we'll provide the ability for users to
actually tag images with some metadata
that we can then use to search on in our
gallery okay cool so we're actually
almost ready to run our first database
migration at which point our gallery
image table will be created with columns
for the title created URL and tags and
that reminds me we should also provide
an int ID could also make it along but
yeah we'll have an an ID and that will
of course be the primary key on each for
our gallery image objects okay so what
I'd like to do next is to actually go
back up into our web project here and
let's take a look at our app settings
that JSON file so you can see we have a
simple JSON object here that specifies
this logging object which has sort of
key value pairs for some some things
that we'd like to configure perhaps
regarding logging
we have this app sitting stat
development dot JSON file that looks
like it logs some additional information
here with the the default way that our
application gets built and we only
currently have this development
environment but what it's going to do is
it's actually going to load you know
whatever is in our app settings that
JSON and then whatever is in our app
settings for that particular environment
that JSON file for this series we're not
going to be worrying about configuring
different types of environments we're
just going to be building a simple
version of this application with a
single environment and so in our app
settings that JSON base you know
configuration file what I'm going to do
is create a new object for our
connection strings and then we're just
going to give this connection string and
name and I'm just going to call it
default connection and then we're going
to provide a connection string to a
sequel database so you want to make sure
that you have Microsoft sequel server
installed on your machine and you should
also make sure that you have an instance
of local DB running so let's go ahead
and check that out very quickly so I'm
going to fire up Commander here and if I
just type in sequel local DB info we can
see that I have Microsoft sequel local
DB running mine is called
MS sequel local DB so if we go back into
our default connection here I'm going to
do is set the server equal to local DB
and then escape the backslash and we'll
have Microsoft or MS sequel local eb and
then we can name our database which i'm
just going to call simple image gallery
and we'll set this
trusted connection equal to true and
then will set multiple active results
that's equal to true as well so this is
a pretty standard connection string to a
sequel database which you you know you
may have used something like this before
if you've developed any other asp.net
applications in the past and so now that
we have a connection string setup what
I'm going to do is go back into our
gallery controller and we need to import
our gallery index model and now I'm
going to right click on simple image
gallery and we're going to add a
reference to our data project so we'll
go ahead and do that okay so let's go
ahead and just build the project and it
looks like we have a few errors to clean
up here so let's go to the first one
which is in our data project and the
dbcontext and we need to make sure that
we import the gallery image model that
we just created and so let's go ahead
and rebuild our solution again and we
have one more error to fix here this is
in our gallery index model class and we
should go ahead and bring in the using
here as well so then if I control period
at the top of this file I can remove the
unused directives and we'll go ahead and
rebuild the solution okay so
everything's looking pretty good so now
let's head back up into our web project
and into the startup class here and what
I'm going to do is down in our configure
services method I'm going to go ahead
and say services dot add DB context and
here we need to specify our simple image
gallery DB context
and then we can pass it some options
here on this lambda and we'll say use
sequel server and then we need to
actually pass it a particular connection
string that we'd like it to connect to
so say configuration dot get connection
strings is all provided for us which is
kind of nice and then we just pass it
the name you know the key in our JSON
file that we were just working with a
few moments ago which is default
connection oops and extra parens here as
well so I'm just gonna move this down to
another line so you can kind of see it a
little bit better and so this connection
string default connection again
corresponds in our app settings that
JSON here to this default connection in
our connection strings so it's kind of
nice how simple that is to point our
application to the particular database
that will be interacting with okay and
actually we need to go back and take a
quick look at our gallery image object
and what I'm going to do here on our
tags is rather than make this a
collection of strings what I'm gonna do
is make this a virtual enumerable of tag
and will actually create another domain
model for tags that images might have
otherwise when any framework tries to
create this gallery image table it's not
really going to understand how to map
just a collection of strings - you know
this object and so we could specify it
as unmapped but on the other hand I
would like to actually use the tags to
query for objects in our database so I'm
going to represent that as this tag type
so in our models we'll go ahead and
create another class
called tag and actually let's call it
image tag make it public and will very
simply just give it an int ID and then a
string description okay so then back in
our gallery image class we're going to
rename this image tag and so now we'll
have a collection of image tag objects
that may correspond to a particular
gallery image so we have a sort of
one-to-many relationship here where a
single image may have many different
image tags and I'll just go ahead and
clean up a single unused using here and
now finally we'll head back into simple
image gallery dbcontext and we'll add a
DB set here for our image tags as well
okay so we're gonna go ahead and try to
run our first database migration for our
application here so to do that we need
to head to the package manager console
and we can get there from view other
windows package manager console and
we'll just be sure that the default
project is set to simple image gallery
data and then we'll add migration and
then in quotes initial migration so
we'll try to run this and you can see
that it has now run it's created a
migrations folder in our data project
and then we have a simple initial
migration c-sharp file here and you can
see what it's it's essentially doing so
entity framework has taken a look at our
DB context class and the gallery image
and image tag DB sets that we've created
here and what it's going to do is look
into these classes and check and see if
it has a table in a particular database
you know if the database even exists at
first it's then going to check to see if
it has tables mapped to either of these
classes if not it's going to go ahead
and create them and it's going to create
columns corresponding to each of the
property
that are on these classes and you can
kind of see that happening here if you
just take a peek at this the code that
was generated here in our migration
class you can see we have this migration
builder object and then we have methods
like create table on it and we're
specifying a name for the table and some
columns you could of course manually
edit these migration files too if you
want to make some kind of change I
wouldn't necessarily recommend it and
you can also see that it is setting the
primary keys that are getting mapped to
the ID property on each of our objects
and also this foreign key relationship
is getting created that is linking our
gallery images over to the image tags so
that looks pretty good now all we need
to do is actually run the command update
database and so what this is going to do
is essentially make a connection to
sequel server that's running locally
here and it's going to go ahead and
create this new database for us and do
our first our first migration here so
we'll have a schema with these two
tables in it okay it looks like I'm
getting an error here that says it was
an error occurred while stablishing a
connection to sequel server the server
was not found or was not accessible be
verify that the instance name is correct
and that sequel server is configured to
allow remote connections the specified
local DB instance does not exist
so what I'm going to do to troubleshoot
here is to just go ahead and open up
sequel server management studio and
we're just going to connect to local DB
/ms sequel local DB and go ahead and see
if we can connect okay so that's looking
good we have a number of different
databases that I've created in the past
year so I know that we have a connection
so let's go ahead and just check our
connection string just kind of double
check and make sure that we have set
that up correctly so we'll head back
into app settings that Jason I'm going
to move this off to one side here and
then we'll take a look at sequel server
management studio and I see our typo
here so this should be a mess sequel
local DB so I'm going to go ahead and
maximize
again and be sure you get your
connection string right I typed mine
incorrectly here but we should be trying
to connect to local DB in parens and
then an escaped backslash and that's
equal local dB we have two S's here and
I had previously just provided one s so
let's go ahead and try to rerun update
database and so it's making a connection
to our local DB instance and it's going
to go ahead and create this simple image
gallery database and you can see that it
says done so if we head back into
Microsoft sequel server management
studio and then I'm just gonna click
refresh here on our local DB instance
and then expand databases and now we can
see this simple image gallery database
among the list of databases that you may
already have on your machine if we
expand this and then expand tables we
can also see now that we have a gallery
image table with an ID created title and
URL and an image tags table here that
just has an ID in a description and then
a foreign key back to a particular
gallery image ID okay so that's looking
pretty good
we'll just go ahead and minimize sequel
server management studio for right now
and I'll close my app settings and we
can also close the package manager
console for the time being I'm just
going to go ahead and also close all the
tabs and if you're tracking this project
using git and this may be a good time
perhaps a bit late but this may be a
good time to make a commit
okay so back in our project here we had
started building this gallery controller
before we created the data layer for
application and ran our first database
migration so we had decided that we were
going to have a gallery index where we
would actually use the gallery index
view model to display some images and
the ability to post a search query on
this page so let's go ahead and before
we actually use our our back-end here
and some services to either push or pull
our own data onto the page here let's
just go ahead and create the sort of
mock some mock data that we can use just
just to demonstrate how the controller
and the view model and the view are all
working together so you can see that
anytime we have this gallery index model
we need to supply some images as a list
of our gallery
image object and potentially a search
query here that the user could use in
like a search form and so what I'll do
is probably just have three sort of mock
images that we can then pass to our
image list so we'll say images is equal
to some image list that will actually go
ahead and create so we'll do that just
above here our image list is equal to a
new list of gallery images
it's yeah we don't need the semicolon
here and here we can just go ahead and
build that out so we'll specify a title
and let's just go ahead and build out
three images for our sort of mock
implementation but our first image will
have a title of say like hiking trip or
something URL we will provide in just a
little while here created we can have
date/time now and then tags will just
mock out a quick like hiking image tags
collection that we will specify above
here this would be a new list of image
tags and let's go ahead and create
another set of tags here and we'll call
this city image tags and so what we'll
do is we'll create two more gallery
images in our sort of demonstration here
so we have one for hiking trip one title
we'll say you know on the trail we'll
provide a URL here in a moment and again
we'll we'll hook it up with the hiking
image tags and then for our third
gallery image we'll just title it
downtown and for the tags here we can
provide it the city image tags okay so
if we head back up here into our tags
we'll do is we'll just have some sort of
mock objects here we'll say a tag one is
a new image tag and the description will
be like adventurer and we'll make the ID
zero and I'll create
just three different tags here so we'll
have adventure and then maybe we'll have
one called
urban and we'll create a third tag here
and we'll make the description like New
York with an ID of two so these are just
sort of mock objects again that will
eventually be provided back by our own
data and then we'll have a service that
actually you know handles passing these
these particular instances around so for
now we'll just go ahead and create three
mock tags with descriptions and ID's so
I'm just going to go ahead and fold
these and then we have a new image list
here that has three gallery images in it
each with a title and empty URL for the
moment created on of date/time now and
one of our image tag collections so the
thing that we forgot to do here is we'll
say having image tags dot add tag one
and then city image tags dot add range
and we'll just go ahead and add range
tag two and tag three and here we need
to say new list of image tag okay
so now we have a collection of hiking
image tags that contains the single tag
here adventure and then our city image
tags contain the urban tag and the New
York tag as well and then in each of our
gallery images I assigned one of these
collection of tags to map to this tags
property that is on our each of our
gallery image objects okay so that's
looking pretty good
go ahead and collapse each of these so
we'll have an image list of three
gallery images each of which should have
all their properties except for the URLs
and then we have our view model here in
which this images property gets set to
the image list that we just constructed
and our search query will just make an
empty string for the time being
now let's go ahead and again just for
demo purposes fill out the URLs here's
will provide some URLs now that you know
won't be hosted ourselves but will be
hosted remotely so what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna head over to pixels and we'll
just find a few images to use very
briefly so I'll just search for hiking
and we'll scroll around until we find a
nice image that we might want to use so
this one looks pretty good
if we select download we can see the URL
for this particular file you definitely
don't want to have a reference to
someone else's hosted image if you're
using it on your own website again this
is just strictly for demo purposes so
we'll go ahead and paste that in our URL
here and shortly after we demonstrate
this we will be replacing it with our
own images that the user can then upload
to our application so then we have
another hiking image so we'll go back
and just select something else likewise
we'll get the URL for this image and
then we have one more image to crab here
and we'll go ahead and grab this URL all
right very good let's go ahead and save
this and so we have a sort of knockdown
index action here well the view model
that will actually pass down is mocked
out so let's go ahead and create our
view now so I'll open up the solution
Explorer and just go ahead and pin it
and then in views I'm gonna open this up
and will collapse home I'm just gonna
right click here and add a new folder
and we'll call this gallery and then in
gallery we'll add a new item and we'll
make it an MVC view page called index
that's CS HTML I like to just create a
vanilla view without having visual
studio scaffold it out because sometimes
it provides more than we actually need
and so at the top of our view here we'll
be using razor syntax to specify the
model that we'll be using on this view
so we'll do that with a spiral model
with lowercase M and then here we need
to provide
the actual model so we'll go into our
models namespace and then gallery index
model will be what we're using here so
what I'm gonna do is just go ahead and
create a simple div of class container
body content and then we'll make a div
of gallery content and then what I'm
going to say is just at for each of our
image and capital M model images we are
going to create a new div class gallery
- image and we'll just have this be an
empty div for the time being now we need
to go define some of these classes in
our CSS so we can do that if you expand
this ww root directory here this is
where all the static files for
application are getting served up from
and then we have this CSS folder that
contains our site dot CSS so you can see
that we have just a minimal amount of
CSS defined for us here we could create
a new to specify some custom CSS but in
our case I'm just going to go ahead and
create it in this file so I just need to
define a few new classes here we have
this gallery content and gallery image
the remaining classes here are coming
from what's been defined in our
application already note also that
because we use the template we also have
bootstrap available to us so let's go
ahead and create a gallery content and
gallery image class and we're going to
stay here for gallery image is we'll
specify some padding of say 8 pixels and
then for our and then we'll specify a
default background color of white a tiny
border radius of 2 pixels we'll
display:inline-block and we'll specify
an explicit width and height of 300
pixels
I'm going to give just a little bit of
margin as well maybe we'll make this 12
pixels and position:relative I'm just
going to supply a little bit of box
shadow on this element fairly
transparent here okay so it's kind of
specifies for the little container that
each of our images will be contained in
and then our gallery content container
will specify a bit of padding as well
and we can make additional modifications
to that if we need so let's go back into
our view so we now have definitions for
both of our CSS classes that we're
implementing here and then we have a for
each loop where we're actually looping
through each of the images that we'll
pass you know whatever model gets passed
this is view and though we may not want
to put it out on the screen you know in
the final application just to kind of
demonstrate how this is working we can
also just throw out the title we'll wrap
in a span onto the page too just to show
some of that data and then maybe in
another for each we can say var tag and
image tags we can create an unordered
list oops
and the UL so I obviously need to go
outside of this for each of our tag
description
and so now we have a sort of nested for
each loop here so we'll have the set of
gallery images and then on each of those
images for each of that images tag we'll
put the tag description out to the page
as well again just kind of a simple
version to demonstrate how we can get
this working let's go ahead and build
our solution and I'm gonna go ahead and
make it commit as well all right so
let's go ahead and just fire up is
Express and we don't have a link in our
app yet to the gallery controller so we
can just at the URL provide slash
gallery and so you can see already that
we are getting three of our images out
to the page here so we don't actually
have the images themselves we're getting
the tags out and it looks like we have a
slight issue here with a title so let's
go ahead and fix that here we need to
provide a spiral for image title if we
go back and refresh now we can see the
titles so let's go ahead and get these
images out to each of their sort of
containers here and the way that I'm
going to do that is provide some inline
CSS here on our gallery image div so
provide a background image and set the
URL equal to at image URL okay so we'll
save that and go ahead and refresh our
page so now we're getting an unrealized
version of each of the images what we'll
do in the future for our own images is
actually implement some image magic here
to actually crop the images that a user
would upload to their application but
for now we could also just you know
resize this using a little bit of CSS
it's not ideal because the user still is
actually accessing that large version of
the image and then just getting it
styled down to size but let's go ahead
and do that for now anyway
back in our CSS and our site that CSS
what I can do is say background size
100% background-repeat:no-repeat and
background position center and so if we
refresh the page now you can see that
our images aren't square so we're not
actually cropping them but they are now
fitting within each of our containers we
could say if we want to just it to look
a little bit perhaps nicer without doing
any actual cropping here we could say
100% 100% and then if i refresh now the
image is sort of sized to the entire
cell but that you can see that there's
some distortion going on as the image is
stretched there's perhaps even a better
way rather than to you background size
100% at all we could just say cover and
if we refresh now we can see that the
image is just essentially fill the
maximum amount of area they have in
their div of course some of the image
gets cut off but we don't have any
distortion and what I'd like to do now
is maybe to put a little bit of just a
tiny border around each of the image
containers it's the way that I'm going
to do that is I'm actually going to nest
the gallery image in a gallery image
container and the gallery image
container will be what contains many of
the properties that are currently on our
gallery image so for instance the
padding background border-radius display
height width margin position and box
shadow and so now this padding if we
nest a gallery image div inside of our
container should provide us with that
little bit of white space around each of
the images so let's go back into
index view and just go ahead and wrap
this div in a negative of class gallery
image container and then I'll move the
span with a title and the list of tags
outside of the container and I'll just
clean up some of this a little bit and
just double check our CSS go ahead and
save this
and now go ahead and refresh the page
and we're not actually seeing our images
here so let's see what the issue is we
need to specify actually a height in the
width on our gallery image as well so
we'll make thee is 280 by 280 pixels and
so yeah we get the images out to their
containers now so the styling isn't
perfect but it just gives us kind of a
very quick and dirty starting point the
next thing that I'll do is go back into
index here and to our gallery content I
will also make this a row so just kind
of like a bootstrap row here and then
now that we understand that we are
indeed passing the title and the
collection of tags out with our model
I'll go ahead and remove those as well
and then refresh the page and this
should give us kind of more of a gallery
look here okay so we have our images out
to our gallery view so now what I'd like
to do is to go ahead and first of all
we'll make it commit because we didn't
make a commit in the last video
and now what I'm going to do is create a
new project here for our services so we
need to stop the server and then I'll go
ahead and create it here so we'll add a
project and I'm gonna call it simple
image gallery dot services and again we
can rename the default class here so the
first service that will create will be
our image service so let's just go ahead
and rename class one to image service
and we wanted to implement an interface
eye image so first of all let's rename
the actual file to image service and
then in our data project we'll be where
we actually specify this interface so
we'll go ahead and create a new class
and we'll make it an interface and we'll
call it ima we'll make this interface
public and then over in our image
service you can see that we now need to
actually provide a reference to our data
projects let's go ahead and do that
we'll add a new reference we'll select
our data project and select ok and now
we can go ahead and import that
namespace and so let's go ahead and
decide what methods we would like to
define on this I
interface so we have a relatively simple
idea for this application so I don't
want to over complicate things we'll
just have a few different methods in
this service that we could actually
implement later on in our controller so
maybe we'll provide the ability for
whatever implements this interface to
return a collection of our images and
for this we need to import the correct
namespace for this as well and we can
just have a method that gets all of the
images
we'll have a method that returns a
particular image by its ID and then
maybe we'll also have the ability to
return a collection of images by a
particular query that corresponds to
some tags that might be on that image
and so we'll have a method that we can
pass a string that will then return a
collection of gallery images that
contain a tag whose description
corresponds with the tag that we pass
this get with tag method and this will
be enough to start with we could
definitely either refactor or create new
methods or change the overload for this
method as we develop the application but
this should be enough to get us started
so if we go down to our image service we
can then control period to implement
that interface that we just created and
if you're using resharper you'll see
some options here otherwise it should
just go ahead and populate the methods
that are required to implement this
interface and so what we're going to do
now is create a constructor for our
service and we'll provide it with our DB
contacts and then we'll create a field
here private read-only field
and then in the constructor we'll just
go ahead and set it and so we can do now
is in our get all method we have a
reference to this DB context and so we
can simply return see TX dot gallery
images and we can call include here
bringing it in any framework or and just
go ahead and conclude and include the
image tags along with our query so now
anytime we invoke this method to get all
the gallery images from our database we
will also have their tags with them so
that's good let's go ahead and fill out
this gift by ID method next in fact I'd
like to go ahead and just move this
perhaps just below get all and here we
can return CTX gallery images defined
and we want to pass it in ID so we need
to pass an ID to our gift by ID method
so we need to head back in to our
interface and actually pass that in to
the method here okay
so we can go back now to our service and
so this will return the instance of the
gallery image that corresponds to the ID
that we pass our get by ID method and
then finally in our get with tag method
we can simply call get all dot where the
image tags dot any tag tag description
is equal to the tag description that
will pass this method and in fact we
should not name this tag since we're
actually using that here as well as the
parameter that we pass this method and
of course we need to go ahead and return
this
also ma'am just clean it up a bit here
okay so here we should get all of the
images where the tags on that image
contain a description that matches this
string that we pass our gate with tag
method so we'll be using this shortly in
the future when we actually build out
our our search box that we can use to
query our own images with for now let's
go ahead and implement this get all in
order to actually get all of the images
that might be in our database and
display them in our gallery view so
we'll head back up into our web project
and then in our gallery controller what
I'm gonna do is we can go ahead and
remove some of this sample data that we
created so I minimize image list
collapse it and go ahead and just delete
it likewise with our tags
so we'll create a new image list and
what we're going to want to do is invoke
an instance of this image service that
we just created to get all method on
that instance and so what we need to do
is actually we're going to be using
dependency injection to inject the
service into our controller so what
we'll do just the top of our controller
class is have a private read only eye
image I'll call it image service and
then we'll create a constructor for this
class which will actually have an eye
image on it so we'll call it our image
service and then we can set the field so
the controller doesn't really care about
our service class per se the controller
only cares that it receives some class
that implements the interface that we
defined with these methods of course our
our service implements this interface
and so now we just need to tell the
application what to actually pass its
controllers when it asks for a specific
you know purpose in this case our image
interface so we can actually do that in
our web project in the start up that CSV
file so if you recall down in our
configure services method we can now add
a scoped service to this method so we
can say a services that adds scoped to
our image service class and for this of
course now we're going to need to
provide a reference in our web project
to our service layer so let's go ahead
and right click on the project and we'll
add a reference to our services layer
and now I should be able to control
period here and go ahead and import the
missing reference
okay awesome so now this is kind of nice
again leveraging dependency injection
here our gallery controller once again
is completely decoupled from our
database
it just says hey I need some methods
that do the following I expect to be
able to get all the images get with a
particular tag and get with you know get
by ID I don't care what class is
implementing it and our start up here
when we configure services we say well
we're using our image service to
actually implement this interface and so
anytime a controller or any other class
here is asking for an implementation of
our image service it's going to get
mapped to the concrete image service
class that we just created okay so now
down in our index action here I need to
correct some spelling here so now we're
actually invoking that image service and
we're going to call get all and use that
to actually set the value of this images
property that's on our view model so our
view model here has this images property
and it just takes this collection of
gallery image which is an entity model
that can get returned from our database
and it's going to use that again to set
this images properties so that we can
use the same view that we just
constructed this time instead of having
that those mock objects will actually be
using whatever records are in our
database which is of course currently
nothing we just have an empty database
with our schema so I'll go ahead and
make it commit here you can see what we
did get status and we're gonna get add
everything and get commit create service
layer implement image service and so
back in our gallery controller this
should work but we should essentially
return a page with some empty results so
let's go ahead and just fire up the
server and confirm that's the case
and we'll just visit slash gallery and
so yeah you can see we just have an
empty page because we don't actually
have any records in our database so
let's fix that
we'll work locally first before we
eventually wire things up with Azure
blob storage what I'm going to do is I'm
going to revisit pixels and we'll search
for some people skateboarding and so
let's just go ahead and download a small
version of this image and we'll go back
and we'll download a small version of
this image and perhaps one more here it
will download a small version of this
image and then what I'll do is I'll
search for images of boats I searched
for bor which is not a boat you could
use poor images as well if you like I'll
go ahead and download this picture and
we'll do one more for our demo we'll go
ahead and grab this one looks like a
pretty cool boat alright so we've got
five images downloaded and now what
we're gonna do is we're gonna move those
downloads into our static files here in
the www root directory so under the
images folder which should be created
for you since we use the template I'm
just going to delete these banners you
can go ahead and just up stop the server
first and then just go ahead and I said
delete these banners and then what I'm
gonna do is just navigate to my
downloads where we just downloaded these
images and we'll go ahead and grab the
five that we just downloaded and I'm
just gonna drag those directly into this
images directory and I'm gonna go ahead
and rename them as well so we have a
couple boats and then the rest of them
are of people skating so they'll have
boat one and two and then skate one two
and three okay so what I'm gonna do just
to create some mock data for us is to
actually run a sequel insert on our
calorie image table so let's go ahead
and do that we can just right click on
the database and run a new query here
and if we select star from gallery
images now you can see that we have an
empty table
first of all also make sure that you are
running it against the database simple
image gallery or whatever you name the
database for this particular series so
what we're going to do is we're going to
insert into gallery images creative
title and URL and you can see that URLs
at keywords I'm just going to wrap that
for safety in square brackets here
values and now we need to write an
insert here for each of the five images
that we just dropped in our static files
directory so for creative we can just
say get date and then for title we'll
have like my new boat and so you can see
that it's going to be here under images
slash boat 1 dot jpg and so if we just
provide the URL at slash images but one
dodgy JPEG that should work and then
we'll do the same for the other images
here so we had five I can say out
sailing this will be boat two and then
we'll say skatepark skateboarding and
whatever else skating so not being very
creative here with the titles but just
to show you how you could first run a
manual insert to create some data to
start working with just to verify the
functionality of your service layer so
we'll go ahead and run this insert and
I'll say five rows affected so if we
select from gallery images now we can
see those five rows and so that's
looking pretty good
go ahead and minimize sequel server and
so now when get all gets called from our
image service it's going to use the DB
context to actually query our database
for all of our images we don't have any
tags yet but that shouldn't matter at
this point let's go ahead and just fire
up the server and so we'll just go ahead
and visit slash gallery and so you can
see that indeed we are getting those
images back from our database so these
are getting served up directly from our
static files directory so that's pretty
cool looks pretty good so I'm gonna go
ahead and fix up the the navbar now so
that we can just visit gallery by
clicking on let's say like the sort of
like the home link here so I'm gonna go
ahead and minimize this and stop the
server you'll notice in the web project
here in views we have a shared directory
and then we have this layout folder or
layout file here and it's got a bunch of
stuff scaffold it out for us this
actually represents the you know the
entire wrapper for all the views in this
simple application they get injected
right here where we have this spiral
render body method getting calls this is
razor syntax once again to in a sense
render any of the views in our
application right here in this div you
can also see some other things in this
file we won't get into all the details
for this simple series in our case all
I'm gonna do is just go ahead and for
our purposes I'm just going to delete
the div that contains the links at the
top of the page and we'll call the
gallery controller index action here you
can see we're using ASP tag helpers here
which is really nice so we're
constructing an anchor tag here a link
with the ASP controller set to gallery
ASP action set to index and I'm just
using it you know sort of as a standard
anchor tag with this kind of nice syntax
so it's just a basic anchor tag here but
razor will actually interpret it and
essentially provide you with the route
that corresponds to this controller and
action combination so that's kind of
nice and that's fine our app can still
be called simple image gallery that's
I'm gonna go ahead and remove this
button and the other thing that I'll do
is in our startup class if we scroll
down we can say that the we can see that
we're setting the default controller to
home let's set the default controller to
the gallery index so this way when our
application starts we will just
immediately hit the gallery index let's
go ahead and try this out now okay cool
so you can see that you know even though
we're in the root of our application it
is serving up the gallery index action
and if we click on simple image gallery
this is where we get taken so we don't
have any other views in the system right
now we need to create two of them we
need to create a detail view so that
when we click on an image we actually
visit a detail view of that image and
we'll need to also create a form page so
that we can actually upload new images
from our computer to get displayed here
so what I'd like to do is to go ahead
and wrap these in links so that when we
click on them we can then be taken over
to a detail view where we can see a
larger version of the image as well as
its description and perhaps its tags as
well so let's go ahead and do that so
yeah so here's our layout and actually
while we're here in this layout page
that I have open so this is our our
layout that's this HTML file and if you
need to find that again that is once
again in our shared directory inside of
our views in our web project here and
while I have this open what I'm gonna do
is just go ahead and actually create a
link here in the nav bar to an upload
page which of course we haven't created
yet but it will serve as kind of a
placeholder for that and we might as
well add it while we're here in the
layout so directly after this div of
class navbar header where we have the
title of our application and go ahead
and create another div and we're going
to just give it a Neve our
collapse collapse and then we're going
to create an unordered list here with
just a single item for now but we'll go
ahead and give you all a class of nav
and then snap our nav class as well and
then here we'll just have upload and
then we're going to go ahead and wrap
this and some tag helpers here so this
will be the asp controller and if you
recall the controllers that we currently
have are just the gallery controller in
the home controller so what I'm going to
go ahead and do is create an image
controller that will then have an upload
action so we'll say ASP action is equal
to upload and yeah we just need upload
to the inside of this anchor tag and the
list element should wrap the anchor tag
since there's only one of them here I'm
just going to go ahead and put this out
separate line if we take a look at the
page and refresh it we should now see
this upload link which currently leads
nowhere because we don't have an image
controller or an upload action ok so now
let's get back to the task of creating
links around each of the images that
appear in our gallery and then having
those take us over to a detailed view so
for that we need to go into our views
and then the gallery our index view here
and you can see that we have this for
each we're iterating over the collection
of images that's on our view model and
we're currently just putting out this
dative of class gallery image container
and then we have a container for the
image itself what we're setting the
background image URL equal to the URL
property that's on any particular image
and so quite simply here I can just
create another tag helper and we're
going to use the gallery controller in
this case we could use the image
controller as well and have like an
image slash detail
action I don't mind putting this in the
gallery controller we have a pretty
minimal application as it is so let me
say is the action is equal to detail and
then we are going to need to tell the
controller action which image in our
collection to display on the detail page
so what we can do is just go ahead and
say SP route ID is equal to at image dot
ID okay so if we just save that and then
if I go refresh the page here you can
see now that these are clickable
elements and if you take a look down and
at the bottom of your browser where
these are leading you can now see that
they will be corresponding to the ID
that's on each of these images so if I
click it you know we're currently
getting taken nowhere because we need to
go ahead and create this action now so
I'm gonna go back and I'll minimize the
browser and now I'm just gonna go ahead
and stop the server and I'm gonna make a
quick commit this over and now I'll
mention this also in the comments below
but between the third video in this
video I had done recording and then I
lost some of the video files and so I
had to kind of work backwards and so I'm
on a separate branch here because I had
been a little bit further along in the
code so that's why this is on a
different branch here and why you don't
see master yeah okay it's just a minor
note in case you're wondering so we can
go ahead and say let me add these and
they can commit ed upload link to your
navbar
links around gallery images and we'll
just go ahead and push those okay so now
let's go into our gallery controller and
as you recall we have this image service
that we have injected into our
controller this allows us to grab the
images we can also use it to grab an
instance of an image in a particular
image by its ID which is exactly what
we'll do for our detailed views
so currently we have this index action
let's go ahead and create an action
action result detail and we'll have an
int ID which will be the ID that
corresponds to the the image that we
want to visit and so we'll go ahead and
store a reference to that image in a
variable here so we'll just call it the
image and we can invoke our image
service to get by ID the ID that we pass
this detail method and so you can see
that this is going to pull back an
instance of one of our gallery image
objects and we're just going to push
that into a view model we could pass the
entity object itself sort of a you know
as a domain model to this page but I
like to make view models for each of my
pages so we'll say that the model is
equal to a new gallery detail model and
let's go ahead and actually create this
model so this again is a view model and
it's going to be here in our web project
in the models namespace and there are
models folder here so I'm going to right
click and just simply add a new class
gallery detail model and what we'll do
is is essentially for an Alf just for
the simple app here it's really going to
map one to one to our domain model so
we'll have an ID property that we need
and something that someone has mentioned
in the comments recently which is you
know kind of nice if if you prefer to
use this a little shortcut here where
you can type prop and it's a code
snippet in Visual Studio if you're
coding in individual studio then if I
hit tab twice here then this kind of
scaffolds out a simple property for us
here I'm using them and so it's just
about as fast or at least it's
comfortable for me to just type it or to
copy and paste a bunch of properties
that wants to so you know whatever suits
your personal preference but just to
know I'm just a little code snippet that
you may want to be aware of particularly
if you are building larger poco classes
out so we'll go ahead and create the
title property for our image and we can
also create like a list of strings for
the image tags and for that we need to
go ahead and bring in collections all
right so if we just recall the actual
image model in our data project here
where we actually specify the entity
model gallery image we also have a
created on we have this you know
enumerable collection of image tags in
our case oh yeah f12 here we can see
that a tag is just an ID in a
description for our view model the tags
for you know as far as the viewer is
concerned are just strings and so we're
just going to simplify that in our view
model when when the user clicks on the
clicks on the image detail view they can
just see a list of strings regarding the
image tags okay and the URL here is the
URL which represents the path on disk
whether locally or remotely to the image
itself let's go back to our view model
that we were just working on and I think
I will also here
dude the daytime for the created and of
course the URL so this maps as I said
almost one-to-one to our entity model I
just prefer to keep it separate just
because we're using view models and
other places in the application and I
just tend to like to keep my entity
model separate and use them strictly for
the purpose of designing the overall
architecture for the application and
then things like our view models
basically consume some of their
properties and then can maybe be any
number of different combination of
properties on any number of those models
but if you're building something
extremely simple which in fact we are
then you may even just consider using
the entity models here in the views okay
so let's head back into our gallery
controller and so now let's populate our
model so the ID will clearly be the
image ID the title will be the image
title created on likewise actually I
caught it created in the entity model
that's fine URL is equal to image URL
and then for our tags so what we have
here on our view model again is a
collection of strings or more
specifically a list of strings but the
tags that are on our image object are
actually a collection of our tag models
so this image tag entity model and so
what we can do is just simply call like
select here and we'll say like T dot
description not to list and so we can
put this in a separate method if we want
to kind of clean up the construction of
this view model but it's pretty simple
so we're just basically getting all the
descriptions for each of the images that
are in this tags collection and then
them into a list and then setting the
tags property on our detail model to
that list so it's pretty straightforward
so we can just go ahead and return the
model to our view and I just fix my typo
here so this is an extremely simple
action result basically just getting an
image by ID from our database by means
of our image service that we've injected
into this controller and then mapping
all the properties that we get back from
that image from our database onto
properties that we define in the
specific view model so now what we need
to do is to go ahead and create a
corresponding view for this so in our
views folder here under gallery we're
going to go ahead and create a new view
and I like to do this manually so we'll
just do MVC view page here and this we
have to call it detail and we're just
going to go ahead and clean this up able
to find our model as our gallery detail
model that we just created and remember
that our views get rendered inside of
our layout so if we revisit our lap here
and we see this render body method this
razor method that's getting called here
inside of this container body content so
anything just as a reminder here
anything that we're creating in our
detail view here is already getting
rendered in our view directly here okay
so back in our detail view I'm gonna do
is go ahead and create a div of class
container by content again this could
could and may very well already be on
the outside of our view but just because
I recall using it here on the index page
will just be consistent go ahead and
create a row
and now we just need to display our
image you know a large version of this
image on the page so I'm going to create
a CSS class here called image detail
container which we have yet to define
that we will and then we have a div of
class image detail and here's where
we'll actually put an image tag so the
image tag will be the URL on the model
and then we can also specify alternate
text here with awe at model app title
and so that way when the user hovers the
mouse over the image they get this
alternate text which will correspond to
the title okay and then I'll create
another row here if classroom and we'll
have a span where we can say title a
model that title again and then below it
here we'll have a second span where we
can say uploaded and here we'll have our
model that created on okay and I'm just
going to have a final row here and here
I'm just going to provide a link back to
the gallery
so we'll style it as a button and we can
use bootstraps button primary SP
controller is equal to gallery a SP
action in a sequel index and we can just
say back to gallery okay and I'll create
custom CSS class here call let's see
there's controls maybe and then here
we'll have one called
image metadata or something maybe image
detail meta okay so with that let's just
go ahead and fire up the server and
check it out all right so if we click on
an image it's like we are hitting
something in our code here
and we're getting a no reference
exception here let's see where we're
getting that so image dot tags is null
our URL is populated created title and
ID are all populated but our image tags
are null so let's go ahead and fix that
so what we need to do first of all we
need to stop the server but then we need
to head into our image service and
before I do that I'm also going to clean
up these usings ok so now we need to
head into our image service which is if
which implements this interface but if
you just f12 here you'll just be taken
to the interface that our service
implements so we need to head into our
service project and then click image
service here ok so what I need to do is
to actually call include here when we
find this image so what's happening is
that this image is getting found but
it's navigation property tags is not
actually getting populated and so we
need to explicitly include those tags
here in our query so rather than find by
ID what I'm simply going to do here is
actually return get all and then I'll
say where the image image stood that ID
is equal to this ID and then we can call
first and so what this is doing is it's
just reusing this get all method here
that we have already where we already
have this include called otherwise we'd
just be repeating some code here where
the image ID is equal to the ID that we
pass to get that ID method and then just
grabbing the first from that collection
so even though there's only one ID in
our database which corresponds to the
idea that we would pass here because
it's a primary key where is always going
to return a collection of objects and so
since we need this method to return an
instance of a gallery image and not a
collection of it we just call first and
grab the only element in that collection
ok so let's go ahead and start the
server again
all right so we'll click on an image and
say yeah this is looking a little bit
better already so I'll leave it to you
if you'd like to do some additional
styling on this page but for now we can
confirm that functionally it does appear
to be working okay and I had to reload
some styles here so sorry about that
okay and I'm sorry about that I just had
to reload some of my CSS Styles here so
if you've been following along since the
beginning of this series then your image
calories should be styled like this as
well with each of these images inside a
container if you will with this drop
shadow so likewise the style on your
gallery detail page may look something
more like this as I said you may want to
add some additional Styles here just to
clean things up so what I'd like to do
now is to go ahead and create an upload
form so that we can actually upload
images and then store them remotely on
Azure so the first thing that we need to
do is to just go ahead and well first of
all stop the server here if it's running
and we're going to create a new
controller but first I'm going to go
ahead and make it commit here and
normally I don't like to store images in
source control but just for the purposes
of this video I'll leave them here so we
added the gallery detail model and the
detail view and we also included tags
and give by ID that's in our image
service
okay so with that taken care of we can
just go ahead and head back into the
code here just gonna close a bunch of
these open windows here so I'm just
going to close all documents and
minimize some of this as well and in
fact if you just click this clap so I'll
button that makes it a lot easier and
now we'll head into our controllers and
what I'm going to do is create a new
image controller here so we're gonna add
a controller and we'll make it an empty
MVC controller called the image
controller so I'll control period to
remove some of these usings
and then if you recall actually in our
layout so here in the shared directory
in our views I created a link to our
upload view here and I specified that it
would be in the image controller and
then the upload action so let's just go
ahead and create an upload action here
and we'll create a new view model and
then we know we're going to return this
model ultimately to the video so let's
go ahead and create our view model and
we'll add it to our models namespace and
we're just gonna call it as we did here
upload image model and it's gonna be a
pretty small model we'll have a string
for the images title and just call it
title and then we'll have some tags
which will represent as a string here
and what we'll do is we'll have a user
who'd like to upload an image specify
some tags like comma separated in a form
text field and then we'll have some
logic in our controller or in a service
layer somewhere where we'll actually
parse out each of the tags that are
separated by commas and then we can
apply those the new image object that we
create and then the next thing that
we'll have here is an eye form file
image upload and this is gonna be a
really useful type it's going to come
from Microsoft asp net core HTTP and so
we can bring that in and then back in
our image controller we don't actually
need to set anything on this upload
image model so we're going to be
presenting the user with an empty form
and then it will be actually up to the
user to fill that form out and then
actually post it back to another action
result that we can get place our
controller here which is going to handle
all of the assigning of the properties
that the user provides to the new object
that will get created and so for that
we'll need to create a post method HTTP
POST so we can use this attribute here
and we'll call this upload new image and
for now we can just return okay we are
going to actually put all the logic of
handling what happens after the user
posts an image here in this HTTP POST
method but what I'd like to do very
quickly is to now just go ahead and
create the view that we can hit that
will contain our form where we can
upload an image so here in views I'm
gonna create a new folder actually
called image and then inside image here
we'll go ahead and create our view and
this will call upload so that it matches
our upload action result okay so here
I'll specify the model
again this will be our upload image
model
and again we'll keep it quite simple
like our other views in this app so
we'll have a row and we'll call this an
upload container that'll be a custom CSS
class we can use and then we'll have a
div of class form actually I'm just
going to call this upload form and we'll
apply our drop shadow and then I will
actually place our form element here so
what we can do is we can actually
specify tag helpers here as well so we
can have an ASP action is equal to
upload new image and then we need to
specify a method of post so that they
can submit this form as a post request
and just double check on the image
controller yeah we call this action
upload new image and we supply the HTTP
POST attribute here the next thing I
need to do is specify this encoding type
here or Inc type and here we need to
declare it as multi-part slash form data
so the Inc type attribute here just
specifies the content type that's used
to submit the form and so like the value
of our method is post and so now we can
provide a specific egg type and so
multi-part form data is what you would
use whenever you want to submit
something like a file up through a form
from the client side so that's why we'll
be using multi-part multi-part slash
form data with our post requests if you
didn't have this here then the image
wouldn't actually get sent with the
request okay
and finally I'm gonna give this form an
ID as well and we're just caught upload
form okay I'm gonna go ahead and clean
this up just a bit as well and here
we'll have a div class form group lips
form group from bootstrap
and let's create a label for just feet
label ASP for title and so you pass ASP
for here just one of the property one of
the properties on your model and then we
can provide our input and do the same
and I'm gonna give this a class form
control here as well
okay I'm gonna create a second form
group here so just copy and paste this
and then what I can do instead of title
here is just delete both these and then
we will create a label input for our
tags and then finally we need to be able
to actually allow the user to upload an
image so and create a third div here and
we're gonna specify a label with class
button button default and button file
which would be a custom CSS class and
here we'll say like browse for image and
then here we'll specify our input so we
can say type is equal to file name is
equal to file and then here's a little
trick we can actually set this an inline
style here of display:none
just because the default input for
floating files through a forum doesn't
really look that good and so instead
we'll just kind of hide it and provide
this button to allow user to click and
browse for the image okay and then
finally here we'll have a div of class
emit and we'll have a button of type
submit' ID will be our upload button or
button upload and the class will be a
bootstrap button button info okay so
let's take a look at what this looks
like now so we'll fire up the server and
if we click upload we can see our simple
form here again we don't have any custom
styling on it and I think in this case I
might like to add just a little bit so
let's go ahead and do that now so we
need to head over into our CSS and one
thing I'm gonna do is I I created this
box shadow let's move this over here so
we can kind of take a look at the code
or the markup and the CSS the same time
so I specified this drop shadow CSS
class here and so what I'm gonna do is
take the box a dough out of our gallery
image container create a new class
called drop shadow and then and then
just paste in the box shadow that I'd
already specified here inside of this
dedicated drop shadow property and then
what I can do is I'll just view the
solution Explorer again and if we head
back into our gallery index so if we go
here to views and then our gallery index
is div class gallery image container I'm
also just now going to add our drop
shadow class too because the drop shadow
something that I would probably like to
use on more than one element throughout
the application so we'll just have a
dedicated CSS class for it here okay
we'll unpin our solution Explorer again
and yes other thing that I'll do while
we're in here editing CSS it's first of
all correct this typo but I'll also go
ahead and add styles for the CSS classes
that I declared on our image detail view
as well so we'll have this image detail
container just with some really simple
stuff here so we'll just do
text-align:left and then we had an image
detail class where I'm just gonna
provide a little bit of padding and
border radius and then we had this
metadata row on our detail page which
included the image title or description
if you will and then the credit on date
or uploaded date so we'll provide a bit
of padding there as well okay so now on
our upload page here let's kind of work
I guess from bottom to top here so we
had this submit button so we had a class
submit and here I'm just going to
provide a tiny bit of padding this
button file I think I'll just provide a
little bit of margin around it so I will
say margin of like six pixels then our
upload form here or we can see this is a
form element and we had an ID of upload
form so we can say upload form provide
some padding will provide auto margins
and a width of 50% so that's going to
kind of keep things centered and then
finally I had this all inside of this
row of class upload container where I'll
just provide another little bit of
padding here so I realized that there's
some duplicate CSS here I'm just going
to leave this here and that you can then
I'll go through and further customize to
your liking so we come here and just
reload yeah and that's not it's not
really necessarily beautiful or anything
but it does start to slightly clean
things up so you can see that we can
provide a title like sample image let's
say that we were going to upload images
about like mountains so we might say
like mountain camping hiking and then we
could browse for the image we could
select one and then we could submit our
form so we obviously don't have anything
happening yet inside of our post method
so let's go ahead and start to wire that
up so I'll go ahead and close the CSS
for now and we'll pin the solution
Explorer back so we'll head into our
image controller and let's go ahead and
just set a breakpoint here on our post
method of upload new image all it's
going to do is just return like a you
know an HTTP 200 response back just is
just to say that everything is working
but of course we don't have anything
happening in this method
nonetheless let's just set a breakpoint
here and what I'll do is just go ahead
and submit the form and so you can see
we hit a breakpoint here so the HTTP
POST is indeed working if we just hit f5
to go through we obviously have an empty
response here next we will actually
complete this HTTP POST upload new image
method and wire it up so that we can
actually post the file contents from
that form up to a sure in order to store
it in blob storage so I've got the
server running here and we're just gonna
take a look at the page
this was the upload page that we had
worked on so we're gonna be able to
supply a title as well as perhaps some
comma separated tags and then we can
browse for an image on our computer and
then submit it and what we'd like to do
is to actually have this submit to file
storage on Azure so let's go ahead and
take a look at how we can get all that
set up so what I'm going to do now is
head over to the azure
portal as it looks today and I believe
you can sign up for a free account and
the free account will give you access to
some services for a limited period of
time or within a certain budget that
Microsoft will provide you if you're
signing up for the first time so I've
got an actual paid adjure account here
like I said this should be free to get
started if you don't yet have an account
so go ahead and create an account if you
don't have one yet and once you do head
over to portal - accom get logged in and
at the time of this recording the
dashboard should look something like you
see here and what we're gonna do is go
over to storage accounts and we're going
to go ahead and create a new storage
accounts I'm just going to click Add
here and this is going to take you
through a little wizard here where we
can just supply some information about
the storage account we'd like to create
I'm just going to go ahead and create
mine here we're just gonna call it
image gallery keep the deployment model
as resource manager and the account Cod
as general purpose make that performance
standard and for replication we're also
just going to use the default read
access geo redundant storage we won't
require a secure transfer for this demo
and I'm gonna use the pay-as-you-go
subscription but like I said if you have
a free account on the be sure to take
advantage of that here you should see
some option to use your free
subscription go ahead and create a new
resource group and I'll leave my
location at a central us so at the very
bottom I'm also going to select pin to
dashboard and then we'll go ahead and
create it so this should just take a few
seconds so once the form submits you
should get this little animation here
letting you know that this storage
account is currently being deployed and
this will take a few seconds to a minute
or so to complete okay so once it's
complete you should see an icon here on
your dashboard if you didn't click pin
to dashboard then you can also access it
from the storage accounts link here and
you should see it in a table so I'm just
going to go ahead and click here
and now you can see some information
about your account the resource group
the status and the location that sort of
thing and so now we want to check out
our access keys so go ahead and select
access keys from settings and what we're
after here is our connection string so
we're just going to go ahead and grab
the first connection string that we have
here and we're going to copy it to the
clipboard so you're gonna want to make
sure you keep these keys secure what I'm
gonna do is actually store these in user
secrets so we're going to use this
connection string to have our
application connect to our new storage
account but what we can do is actually
use something called user secrets with
asp.net in order to keep our connection
string out of our code base so let's go
ahead and take a look at how we'll do
that so I'm gonna leave this window open
I'm just gonna minimize it and what
we're going to do first is actually just
install the secret manager tool in our
application so we're just going to right
click on the web project here in this
case simple image gallery and we're
gonna go ahead and edit the CS proj now
among the item groups where we have died
in CL ID tool references I'm just gonna
add another tool reference here so the
string for our include will be Microsoft
that extensions that secret manager that
tools and at the time of this video
we'll be using version 2.0 point O I'm
just going to go ahead and save and then
I'm gonna go ahead and rebuild the
solution I mean for that we should stop
debugging of course and so the first
thing that happens here is the new get
packages are getting restored including
the new package that we've added here to
our CS proj for managing user secrets so
now we should be able to do is if we
right click on the web project again we
should have the option to manage user
secrets let me go ahead and select this
and what we see here now is a secret
Stud JSON file that's currently empty
well we have the opening and closing
curly brackets but otherwise we don't
have any key value pairs for
our user secrets here so what I'm gonna
do is go ahead and add my connection
string for my storage account here as a
key value pair in this JSON file so I'm
gonna go ahead and just call this a
sharor storage connection string and
then here I'm gonna go ahead and paste
that connection string so be sure to
generate your own and as I mentioned
don't share it with anyone
I'm gonna go ahead and remove this
connection string as soon as I'm done
with this part of the video if we head
back into the CS proj you'll also notice
that what we've done has generated this
user secrets ID node and sort of
auto-generated something like a grid
here but this could really be anything
so the way this is working is that the
secret manager tool is basically storing
this JSON file not with our solution
anywhere but actually on our system so
on Windows this is going to be somewhere
in our app data folder and then in like
the Microsoft folder and then there's a
folder called user secrets so it's not
related to our solution the user secrets
tool will handle all the implementation
details regarding using the connection
string that we specified here so as long
as we have the key value pair stored
here what I can do is basically
reference the azure storage connection
string key here whenever I'm looking for
the connection string we're gonna go
ahead and close our secrets that JSON
again the user secrets ID here is
actually just going to be the name of
the folder in our app data directory
where that user secret is stored on our
system you could rename it here and have
it be something completely different but
I'm just gonna leave it as it is and
we'll go ahead and close our CS proj now
if we head back into our image
controller we're going to use our
applications configuration to simply
access
our new user secret so what I'm going to
do is create a private field at the top
of our image controller class and it'll
be of type I configuration and so for
this we need to bring in Microsoft
extensions that configuration and I'm
just going to call this field underscore
config and I'm also going to create a
field which is just a string called our
Badger connection string and this we
just need to have an accessor for so
we're just going to actually get this
and now we'll go ahead and create our
constructor so that we can use our
leverage dependency injection to get the
configuration for our application
okay a sure connection string is equal
to underscore config and then we just
need to pass it the string that we named
the key in our secrets that JSON file
which was just as your storage
connection string okay so now we can
just make use of that here in our image
controller class so we're going to need
to actually perform a series of steps
here to actually get access to our to
have image gallery if we head down where
we see blob service here and we have
this option to see the various
containers that we might create for our
storage account we don't have any
containers yet and you can see that it's
going to say click put plus container to
get started here so let's go ahead and
add one and we're going to call this
images and for the public access level
I'm just going to go ahead and set this
to blob and we'll say okay so now we
have this new images container on our
storage account so let's go ahead and
minimize here and let's start to write
the various methods that we need to
actually connect to that blob storage
from our controller action so I'm gonna
store our container in a bar here and
I'm actually going to delegate this
responsibility to our image service and
we're going to have a method on it
called get blob container which is going
to take our connection string and the
name of the storage container that we
just created which was images so let's
go ahead and use dependency injection to
inject an instance of our image service
so we'll go ahead and bring in the using
for that from our services namespace
create the private field here and we'll
set it in our constructor okay so now we
have access to a valid image service and
so we just need to write this method get
blob container so I'm go ahead and
control period here to go ahead and just
generate that method then we can f12 to
go over to it so the way this is going
to work is we're just going to go ahead
and store a VAR for our storage account
so we'll have this cloud storage account
and we can go ahead and bring this in by
adding a reference to Microsoft Windows
Azure dot storage and here we should be
able to simply call that parse and pass
it our connection straight next we're
going to store our blob client in a bar
so we'll use our storage account and
we're just going to go ahead and create
a cloud blob client now we need to
return a reference to that container
that we just created so we return blob
client get container reference and we're
going to pass it the string V here which
was just named automatically if we go
back into our image controller here
string V actually corresponds to the
name of the container that we'd like a
reference to so what I'm gonna do is
head back here and we're gonna call this
container name
and we're going to go ahead and use it
to get our container reference and more
specifically than just an object that
this will return a cloud blob container
object so for this we need to bring in
Windows Azure that storage blob and so
all this method is doing is returning a
reference the particular blob container
that we're after or in order to get that
container reference we need to have a
valid storage account which we can
access using our connection string and
then we use this cloud blob client
object in order to get a direct
reference to the container of the name
that we specified so let's go back into
our image controller now now we're going
to be uploading an image so the next
thing that we want to do is to actually
parse what's called the
content-disposition response header so
let's store the content-disposition in a
bar we'll just call this content and for
this we can use content-disposition
header value and we'll need to go ahead
and bring in HTTP headers and here we
can parse the file that we're uploading
oops and of course upload new image
needs to actually take that so as an
argument so we're gonna go ahead and use
iform file for this and we need to bring
in asp net core HTTP and now kind of
disposition header value that parse will
take our files content disposition now
from this we should be able to grab the
file name that's being uploaded
note that we have other properties that
we can access here as well including
just simply the name we have file names
star we have the size and the read date
a few other things here creation date
that might be useful depending on the
structure of your application in our
case we're just going to go ahead and
grab the file name and you'll notice
that when it comes back it's going to
come back with some quotes around it so
what we need to do is to actually trim
those clothes so we've got a container
we're grabbing the file name from the
upload that's coming from our form now
we need to do a few other things here
first of all we need to get a reference
to a blob blob and we can grab that off
of our container object so we'll just
use the method get' block blob reference
go ahead and pass it our filename and
then we can simply upload it so to do
that we can call on our block blob
upload from stream async and we're gonna
allow all this to happen asynchronously
so we'll go ahead and await this we're
gonna make this instead of an I action
result we're gonna make it an async task
I actually resolve type and we won't
return okay and of course to use tasks
we need to also bring in a system depth
reading
and upload from stream async is a method
that we need to go ahead and pass our
file and we can call open read stream on
our file to pass it the stream that it
requires to be uploaded and the other
thing that I'm going to do here is also
go ahead and use our image service to
set our image and we're going to go
ahead and pass it the title from our
form the tags as well as the location
that has been reserved for our image in
blob storage and for that we can grab
block blob URI and then finally we're
going to return redirect to action index
and then we'll just return back to our
gallery so now we need to go ahead and
write this set image method on our image
service so let's head into our image
service so let's go ahead and control
period here to generate that method then
we'll head into our image service and
check it out so this is actually going
to receive a string title and then
string tags that we'll need to basically
parse based on like a comma delimiter
and then the URI
values we go back in addition to the
file in upload new image
we're also passing in those tags and
we're passing in the
title the gallery image okay so well f12
to get back to you set image and what we
need this to do is to basically create a
reference to that new image in our
sequel database so whereas previously if
we select star from images
oops sorry select star from gallery
images you can see that the URLs were
all these relative paths some local
image that we had in our www root folder
we now need this URL to point to the URL
where we now need this URL to point to
the location where the images are hosted
in our Adger blob storage database so
let's go ahead and minimize this so what
we're gonna say is VAR image is equal to
a new gallery image object where the
title is simply the title string the
tags we're gonna create a new method for
parse tags and we'll pass it the string
tags the URL will be the URI created
will be just date/time now just keep
things relatively simple and URI we
actually need to go ahead and grab the
absolute URI
value okay so once we've built up this
new gallery image object we can simply
call on our contacts and go ahead and
add this object
and then Save Changes and we'll save
changes async here and go ahead and
await it so we'll make our tasks async
and now all we have left to do is to
parse these tags that we pass as a
string and we're going to pass this from
the form as simply a comma separated
list of image tags so we're going to
create a public list of image tags and
it's going to take as an argument
obviously our string tags this should be
pretty simple all that we need to do is
to create a tag list and will basically
say tags that split on the comma and
we'll call that two lists here and then
what we can do is iterate over that list
you can say for each of our tag in tag
list we're going to add that to a list
of image tag objects
so let's new up an empty list of image
tags
and so what we can do is put say image
tag stop ad and we're going to add a new
image tag where the description is
simply the tag and now we can return our
image tags list we could also refactor
this into something a little bit simpler
using link on our two lists here we
could select a new image tag for each of
them where we just set the description
equal to tag this should also work and
it makes things a little bit simpler and
now we can actually just return this and
rather than - let's call it here and
what I'll do is call to list and here I
should make it happy okay so pretty
simple method to parse tags given any
string of comma separated tags provided
by our user and so that should take care
of setting the image in our database we
head back into our image controller we
can kind of see how this is going to
work our user will submit a form that
passes up a file in the form of this
iform file object the form is also going
to contain fields for some tags and an
image title and we're going to use our
image service to get a reference to our
images container using our adjure
connection string we need to go ahead
and parse the content-disposition of the
file that we're passing up so that we
can grab the file name we trim off some
unnecessary quotations then we get a
reference to a what's called a block
blob here we get that reference by
passing it the file name that we grabbed
off of the file that's getting uploaded
and then we call upload from stream
async there to actually pass
that file up to our adjure storage we
also take care of things in our own
database here which simply creates a
reference to that image using the URI
that's coming back from Asher as well as
the title and the tags that the user has
set using the form and we handle all of
that in our image service with the set
image method that we were just looking
at so finally we redirect to the index
action on our gallery controller so the
next thing I want to do is just go ahead
and set a breakpoint here and we're
going to start the application so I'm
gonna head over to our upload form and
we're going to get an exception here
that says in thought operation exception
unable to resolve service for type
simple image gallery services image
service when attempting to activate our
image controller so what's happening
here is we need to make sure that we
actually register our service in our
startup class so let's go ahead and do
that we'll head over to startup that CS
if we scroll down to where we have
configure services looks like we are
adding a scope service of type image
service so yeah I actually wrote the
constructor wrong in our image
controller so it will scroll up we need
this to get past and I image service so
we're going to go ahead and stop this
and so this takes the interface i image
and so we'll go ahead and control period
to bring in a reference to that
interface and we'll do the same here for
our fields that we can set the value and
we'll do the same here for our field
private fields so that it can be set
properly and so as you can see in our
startup class when we're using
dependency injection anytime our
controllers are asking for something
that implements the methods that are
defined on this AI interface it's going
to inject a scope image service and
since we've configured our services this
way we need to make sure
that we are using the interface here in
our constructor just like we used in our
gallery controller as well if we head
back there you can see that in the
constructor for our gallery controller
we are indeed also using the eye image
interface here okay so let's go ahead
and try to start the server up again and
so now I can also remove the reference
to simple image gallery dot services and
now that we're passing in an interface
we need to go ahead and make sure that
the methods that we created on the
service or also defined on the interface
we kind of did that backwards or I did
it backwards
so our image service has three new
methods on it
it's got this cloud blob container type
kit blob container which takes a string
connection string and for this we just
need to make sure that we bring in once
again
Microsoft Windows Azure storage DLL so
we actually need to add a reference to
that we've got we've got a task set
image which takes a string title string
tags and URI we need to go ahead and
bring in our system namespace and we'll
also bring in system dot threading and
then finally we also have a method that
returns a list of image tags called
parse tags which just takes in the
spring of tags okay with that we have
now defined the new methods that we
provided on our image service which
implements this interface and so that
should not be satisfied and I'm just
going to go ahead and bring this back
into a single pane and it's looking like
saying that we are not implementing the
interface member gibb blob container
string oh I see we also need to modify
eye image
to pass in our container name as well as
a string okay so if we go back into our
image service that's looking pretty good
so we'll head into our image controller
and we've got our break point set here
on the post method so I'm just going to
go ahead and start the server back up
again
okay so let's head over to our upload
forum and we're just going to call this
test image and four tags will say hiking
and adventure I'll go ahead and browse
for an image just like this one and
we'll just go ahead and click Submit so
now you can see that we have a reference
to our file as an eye form file you see
that we have the file name and the
content type as well as this content
disposition we've got our tags being
sent up here as this string and we have
the title as well so let's hit f10 and
we try to implement our image service to
get a reference to the blob container so
now we have this container object you
can see the storage URI which contains
the URI to our storage account that we'd
set up I'm going to hit f10 here to get
the content and then if then again to
get the file name so you can see the
file name is hiked JPEG now we're going
to get a reference to a block blob and
so we can see that object here and then
we'll call upload from stream async here
now we're going to use our image service
to actually set that image in our
database and then finally will redirect
to the gallery so I'm just going to hit
f5 and now we're back in our gallery and
indeed you can see the new image that we
have here in our gallery is the one that
we just uploaded so we can click on it
we can see it full-size we can go back
to the gallery and note that if we
inspect this we can see that the image
source is now coming from to have image
gallery blob that Cortot windows.net
which is indeed hosted
on Asher whereas these other images here
are hosted locally so if we go into our
database and we select star from gallery
images again we can see that indeed the
URL for our test image here is pointing
to our blob storage on adjure so that's
pretty cool we can also now select star
from image tags and we can see that we
have some new records for the tags that
we parsed I can see that we have a
slight bug in that we're including a
space here so we also need to go ahead
and trim out spaces when we parse tags
so that's looking pretty good note also
something pretty important here is that
we don't have that a connection string
that we use to connect to Asher anywhere
in source code so that's currently just
stored locally on the development
machine that we're working on and so we
don't need to actually worry about
having that checked into source control
if you were deploying this to a server
somewhere say a separate dev environment
or like staging or production and you
were running your app on one of those
machines then you might have secrets
stored specifically on those servers
either as environment variables or
through some other means but for
development purposes this is really nice
that we can actually use cloud storage
and not share our connection string
publicly so that's it for this video
thanks for watching and I'll see you
next time